that's what I want is for people like
Tucker and Laura Ingram to stop being
such cowards hiding in their little
media silos you know plowing out their
propaganda to fear monger and brainwash
Their audience because I really have a
personal stake in this people in my life
who are important to me or used to be
important to me no longer think in a
reasonable way they've been scared out
of their wits literally and I think it's
I think a lot of families trumpism is
the symptom of this but I think a lot of
American families would be like you know
what we would be so much healthier and
our family systems would be so much
healthier if there wasn't propaganda
allowed on any side right but especially
on the right where I think it's all
about exalting people's grievance so
that people can hide from their fears
and their vulnerabilities like the stuff
that we have to solve and work out if
we're gonna solve climate change and
inequity and the violence that besets
the culture all these very real problems